hello I'm Julie tario at Stanford
University and I'm delighted to be
taking part in this ibiology talk series
on great problems at the interface
between physics and biology the
particular problem that I would like to
explore with you today is the question
of how we'll go about discovering design
principles for cells and organisms this
I think is a very fundamental question
of biology that reveals itself just when
you look at any living organism and I've
shown you a few examples here at the
cellular level where over on the Left we
have one of santiago ramon e calls
beautiful drawings of neurons in the
brain in the middle we have a light
micrograph of an algae spirogyra where
you can see the beautiful regular
helical patterns of its chloroplasts and
over here on the right we have the
little glass exoskeleton of a diatom
which is a unicellular organism that's
able to build itself this beautiful
little glass house in which to live now
if we were to see these kinds of very
precise robust and delicate structures
in something that was built by a human
we would assume that there was on some
sort of underlying design principle that
the human had chosen to achieve some
function and chosen materials and chosen
a structural organization that would
achieve that function but at the level
of cells in the absence of an architect
there have to be some other kind of
underlying physical principles that
enable this kind of organization to
emerge now we can think about this
problem of cellular self-organization at
many different scales and arguably one
of the first interesting places where
self-organization happens in biological
systems is just at the level of protein
folding and I would actually argue that
at this point we basically understand
pretty well how proteins fold up the
interactions between the atoms and the
protein as its folding are very familiar
from fundamental physical and chemical
principles and we're using just very
basic equilibrium theory it's possible
to predict the folding of a protein with
an astonishing degree of precision
certainly there are details left to
understand but the physical principles I
would say we do understand but as soon
as we start getting to larger scales
then things all get to be a great big
mess so if you take a bunch of these
proteins you put them together you make
a cell if you take a bunch of cells and
you put them together you can make a
multicellular organisms
this mouse embryo shown here and if you
take a bunch of organisms and put them
together you can actually have very
elaborate larger scale kinds of
biological organization one example I'm
very fond of is this termite mound shown
here which is several meters tall and
this enormous and elaborate structure
with little nests and storage rooms down
at the bottom and then a big system of
air conditioning built up top is put
together by little termites that are
only a few millimeters long and I would
postulate that there's not a term I
architect that is telling all the rest
of them where to go instead they're able
to use just local information and local
behavioral rules to put mud together to
build this big structure and I think
that's a very good analogy for what must
be happening at the level of the
organism and at the level of the cell so
fundamentally as we try to understand
this from the level of physical
principles our equilibrium theories that
work pretty well for protein folding
just failed dramatically at all higher
scales of organization so one way maybe
of asking this question about how we're
gonna discover design principles is to
say in the context of protein folding
for example we have a privileged state
the equilibrium state but what would the
equivalent of that be for something that
is like a cell or like an organism with
no obvious global privileged state and
yet is able to generate robust
reproducible and precise forms now
that's a difficult question and I think
it becomes even more difficult and even
more puzzling when you realize that of
course almost all biological structures
are not only precisely defined but also
we're dynamic there's one case where we
can see this very clearly which is cell
motility now there are many different
kinds of cells unicellular organisms or
cells within multicellular organisms
such as humans that are able to crawl
around in a directed and purposeful way
and one of the motile cells that we work
on a great deal in my group is shown
here these are cells from the skin of
fish and they're structural elements can
be highlighted so for example in this
image by my students sunny low she's
used a fluorescently labeled mushroom
toxin to highlight those structures of
all of the actin filaments within this
particular cell so in particular over
here in this movie that was made by a
former student for Tricia yam she's used
essentially the same technique to build
up a little bit of texture in the
podium inside this living cell so as the
cell starts to crawl what I hope you can
appreciate is that the net movement of
the cell arises because the mesh work is
assembled at the front or at the top and
then is disassembled at the back but
remarkably those two rates are almost
exactly identical to one another because
the cell moves forward without changing
its top-to-bottom length
similarly the rate of mesh work is
simply over on the right side of the
cell it's got to be the same as the rate
of mesh work as something over on the
left side so that it's able to move
forward without turning so how is it
that the cell is able to put together
all these very large-scale structure
elements that are constantly turning
over and yet do so with such precisely
balanced rates how does it know how to
make this shape well we don't know the
answer to that but I hope I can at least
take a step back and focus on a slightly
simpler question or what should be a
slightly simpler question to challenge
you with this idea of trying to come up
with physical principles that will
enable cells to do things like measure
length and count things and measure
spacing as they're building structures
and in particular I'd like to focus on a
relatively simple case which is when
cells build structures with filaments
wrapped by membrane that protrude
outward from their surfaces there are
many examples in biology where cells are
able to build these kinds of surface
protrusions that clearly have defined
and measured lengths so for example over
on the left this is an electron
micrograph of a cross-section of the
surface of an intestinal epithelial cell
where you see it's covered with these
little fingers that are sticking up that
are all wrapped in membrane and that are
enable an increase in surface area for
the absorption of nutrients now in the
middle we have a scanning electron
micrograph of a cilia and this is a
single-celled organism that looks all
hairy each of these individual little
hairs is a beating psyllium that the
cell is using to swim around and you can
see both on the intestinal epithelium
and on the cilia that all of these many
hundreds of different surface
protrusions are really pretty much
exactly the same length so it has to
have some way to measure that now maybe
even more interesting case that I'll
come back to is the stereocilia on the
surface of the hair cell in the inner
ear and this little cluster of surface
protrusions is what
Mabel's us to perceive motions in the
air as sound within our brains and you
can see in this case that not only are
these little stereocilia a perfectly
well-defined length but in fact
different stereocilia on the surface of
the same cell all have different lengths
and they organize themselves in this
incredibly precise staircase step
pattern like a set of organ pipes so we
want to be able to come up with some
proposition of general organizational
principles that can allow these kinds of
structures to be built by cells in order
to do that we need to know a little bit
more about their structure in particular
all of these surface protrusions are
made by structural filaments that are
bundled together and then wrapped around
by membrane and those filaments
themselves are also assembled from
smaller subunits and in the cases that
we're going to be talking about these
filaments are actually self assembled by
multiple different copies of identical
subunits and to a first approximation
the same sort of simple equilibrium
theories that enable us to describe
protein folding can also enable us to
describe these very simple sorts of
protein protein interactions that build
in this case helical filaments with just
many copies of the same subunit
interacting over and over again in these
simple systems we can also precisely
measure aspects of their rates and of
their turnover and so for actin
filaments that were that were focused on
today there been a couple of really very
beautiful experiments measuring
precisely all of the rates that governed
their self-assembly and behavior so for
example in this one very famous study
from Compiler done in 1986 he was able
to measure the on rate and the off rate
of individual subunits landing on the
ends of the filaments both on the two
structurally distinct ends and also as a
function of whether the subunits contain
ATP or ADP so all of those numbers are
known ok so if you have a system like
this where you have a bunch of protein
subunits that are able to self associate
is that something that just by itself
can give you a well-defined length well
the answer actually is no it's very
clearly no it's been shown
experimentally and also described
theoretically but if you have this kind
of self assembling subunits then the the
default length distribution is going to
be exponential and the fundamental
reason for that is that each little sub
you
doesn't know what the rest of the
filament is doing its behavior is
governed just by these local rates these
local interactions but because each one
of those addition and loss reactions is
essentially independent the exponential
distribution is the default so we can
get some aspects of filament structure
in particular its diameter and also its
dynamics defined by just the structure
of the protein subunits that make it up
but for length if we want the length to
be some precisely defined number there
has to be some other mechanism for
determining that now of course inside of
living cells filamentous proteins never
operate on their own there are always
lots and lots of other proteins in fact
hundreds or possibly even thousands of
other proteins that interact with these
cytoskeletal filament structures in
order to determine their behavior and
this is a textbook illustration of just
a few of the different kinds of proteins
that affect cytoskeletal filaments and
the details here aren't important but
the basic idea is just for every aspect
of dynamics our structure of these
filamentous proteins there is some other
protein that is able to interact with
those subunits and regulate their
behavior so there are other proteins
that can regulate the on rate and the
off rates of the the subunits at the
ends they can bind to the filaments and
regulate their stability they can force
the filaments to bundle together etc etc
okay so now if we know that there are
other proteins that will interact with
these filament forming proteins let me
go back to our problem of how do you set
a define length you might imagine that a
really easy way to do it would be just
to have a protein whose job it is to
determine that life and in fact there
are some cases of biology where we know
that that happens one very well
characterized case is in bacteriophage
lambda so this is a kind of virus that
infects bacteria and it makes these
spectacular little sort of landing pod
structures and there is a tail that is
part of this structure where if you look
at that tail in many different
individual virus particles as you can
see in the micrograph those tails are
all the same length and it's been shown
that there is a protein called the H
protein big long protein whose length
determines the length of that tail
internal endframe deletions that make
the protein shorter also make the tail
shorter and duplications that make the
protein longer also make the tail longer
so that's great
but it doesn't have to be a protein
that acts as the template it could be a
different sort of macromolecule and in
fact there are other viruses such as
tobacco mosaic virus shown here then
instead of using a protein to determine
their length they use the RNA genome to
determine the length but the idea is
still the same if you have a template
that's a great way to solve this problem
but of course we're not done because the
bottom line is this really simple
elegant idea of having a template simply
doesn't work in any of those cases that
I showed you and the intestinal
microbial life and the silly on the
surface of the swimming organism or in
the stereocilia on the surface of the
hair cell so what determines length in
those kinds of cases and it's got to be
something that's dynamic so let's focus
in particular on these hair stare hair
cells stereocilia because I think this
is just an exquisitely beautiful piece
of biology that's actually filled with
really really interesting questions and
physics now the organization the
stereocilia is I showed you before is in
bundles where each individual protrusion
is a defined length and they're
organized in such a way that the
protrusions line up so that they're each
next to a neighbor that's slightly
longer and the reason why that's
important is because every pair of
neighboring filaments of different
lengths in this structure is attached by
a little structure called a tip link and
when these hair cells in the inner ear
have the the tips of the those bundles
bent by the movements of membranes that
react essentially to fluid flow that
comes downstream of the bouncing around
of the eardrum then the movement of
those stereocilia relative to one
another
causes the slightly longer stereo
sailing to slide with respect to a
slightly shorter neighbor and so tugging
on that tip link then opens ion channels
that enable changes in membrane
polarization which can eventually be
perceived as an electrical signal and
interpreted as sound by the brain okay
so it's obvious that it's very important
that the stereocilia be built a certain
length in a certain pattern on the
surface of the cell and also actually it
turns out that they be tuned to
different frequencies so you can hear
both high pitches and low pitches and I
wanted to share with you just an
absolutely astonishing study that was
done by Lou Tilney and his colleagues
back in the 1980s
that I think shows the magnitude of this
problem and how difficult it really is
going to be to try to understand how it
works and what they did here was a
simple but extremely painstaking series
of experiments where they dissected out
the cochlea from newborn chicks and then
used scanning electron microscopy to
examine the hair cells in different
parts of the cochlea so one end there
are hair cells that are tuned to hear
high frequencies at the other end hair
cells tuned to hear low frequencies and
then graded frequency determination in
between and what they found is if they
looked at the end that could hear high
frequencies they found these short
little stiff stubby stereocilia but if
they looked at the end of the cochlea
that was tuned to hear long frequencies
they found these long elegant sort of
floppy stereocilia okay that's pretty
cool but the really amazing part is they
then went ahead and measured the total
number of actin filaments the total
length of those filaments the total
surface area membrane that wrapped
around all these things for all of these
different cells throughout the cochlea
now turned out that those numbers were
absolutely conserved so there were
90,000 microns of actin filaments making
up each of these very different kinds of
structures there is a hundred and eighty
square microns of membrane that's
wrapped around each of these very
different kinds of structures and yet
each individual cell Tunes the overall
length number and spacing of these
series cilia to be able to hear the
pitch that it's intended to hear so this
means is that you know every single one
of these cells basically started with
the same Lego kit it had the same number
of structural proteins the same amount
of membrane and yet each cell chose to
arrange them in slightly different ways
depending on where it was in the cochlea
and what pitch it wanted to hear
now we don't understand how that works
not only do we not understand in detail
how the length of these structures can
be set but we also don't understand how
those lengths can be so finely tuned in
order to achieve this kind of biological
specificity now that's just one example
but I think it opens up this huge can of
worms about how we can go about
understanding cell structure
determination and I think this is a
subset of the very general question
raised by shortening her of what is life
certainly life has to obey physical and
chemical principles but there are
additional principles that I believe we
have not yet discovered there
necessary to describe these kinds of
processes that we see inside of living
cells and organisms and cells are very
complicated the inside of the cell is
extremely crowded as you can see in this
electron micrograph reconstruction it's
very in homogeneous everything is
constantly far away from equilibrium and
its material properties are very weird
it's not viscous it's not elastic it's
not plastic it's some combination of all
those things and actually can change its
material properties over time so with
all this kind of weirdness and
complexity and strange material
properties how are the cells
nevertheless able to build these
exquisitely regular beautiful structures
that we see all the time well I think
it's very clear that equilibrium
thermodynamics and statistical mechanics
are not going to get us there it's a
good first step but it's not going to
really be able to describe the physical
principles for cell organization in a
living in a real living system and I'd
like to propose that one way to really
try to get at this and to start building
a general theory of the cell is to start
with questions that seem like they might
be relatively simple how the cells
measure things how two cells count
things the hope is that once we
understand the principles underlying
those kinds of relatively simple
processes we should be able to put them
together to understand robust and
dynamic cell organization also in more
complex contexts in complex contexts for
the life of the individual cell and also
in order to build a whole multicellular
organism such as ourselves and at some
point I hope that if we understand these
physical principles in these
organizational principles well enough
then we should be able to also engineer
them and be able to get the cells to
build structures that we choose rather
than just building the structures that
they choose thank you
you